You now have a server sitting out there
on the Internet and this server is doing
a lot of different things and talking
to other devices on the Internet.
Depending on your application it
could be responding to web requests,
database queries, sending and
receiving email, and let's not forget
handling the SSH sessions we've
been using this whole time.
But how does your server know which
application is in charge of handling
each type of request?
The answer is ports.
Each of your applications are configured
to respond to requests destined for
a specific port.
For example, a web server would
by default respond on port 80,
the default port for HTTP.
We can control which ports our server
is allowed to accept requests for
using an application
called the firewall.
We'll do that shortly, but for
now let's explore some common ports.